all right boys a little relationship
advice up now oh i do we're just making
the world
better every episode who would hit us up
for relationship advice
awesome people looking for a [ __ ] a
lot of people yeah you're right actually
that's a pretty good call
what else what do you got here this is
from joseph from columbus ohio you said
joseph what up
king in the sting this is joe that cat
in the back
some relationship advice
my uh my wife
in the back seat yeah okay yeah
and when we go see her family in
california
she hates when i tell them that we met
on tinder
tell anybody her family or friends that
we met on the great side of tinder
um well why don't you tell the truth
brendan let him talk
bro friends you know i like being the
success story that
hey we met on tinder we're married and
now we have a baby yeah like the
frederick douglass attender
yup but uh she also kind of looks like
cat a little bit she has glasses on
but uh okay
that's a stretch do i respect her wishes
and
not tell uh her family how we met and
tell them that we met at the mall
because that's where our first date
make sure the story's not as long as
this one whatever you do
or do i tell them the truth
and that we went on tinder and that it
works
if you um i like it do it right
i feel you all right gang buzz
buzz buzz dog i would tell the truth i
got a couple of things you found that
wife off [ __ ] the asian ordered bride
you didn't meet on tinder bro what are
we doing oh tinder's definitely it's
basically like
uh it's def you can get it you can get
every type of people on space like
farmers only.com but for everyone not
just for whites
yeah it's for yeah you could also you
know this is a real stat i think
60 or 70 percent of relationships in
2018 start
off site you made that up whatever
you can look it up anywhere and you made
it up but what i'm saying is this first
of all
the guy okay the guy
is making a video while he's driving
with his wife and child yeah okay
but this is where you met because you
know where you're gonna unmeet
at the funeral place you're gonna be in
heaven yeah that's what you're gonna be
yeah
how about when he goes me and my wife
goes
first of all your wife can sit in the
front seat bro it is 2019.
yeah i'm not buying this whole thing you
guys met overseas bro
now that i do get that he has a military
type of vibe
and there's nothing wrong with that
either and he also he obviously has that
asian that yellow fever they call it
you know i think no that's a different
that's a disease that killed a lot of
people i think and there's no
no yellow fever is fine you look up
yellow fever for us derek i'm pretty
sure yellow fevers are real
uh look wooly willy is that the name of
the
just drag some more hair onto your face
with your little stencil
or is that the name of coldplay's fan
base yellow fever what is it derek
it's uh read it fast i don't sound
racist you got a disease
caused by a virus that is spread through
mosquito bites
and that's what i'm talking about no
yellow fever is a real thing dude if you
like just asians yeah you got yellow
fever
yeah is that fear cat that's absolutely
fair
it's fair you're not racist not racist
at all and so what does it encompass is
yellow fever
japanese people look kind of whitish i
think yeah some asians look really white
and others look really
brown filipinos are super dark yeah
very very bright oh yeah that filipino
grigio how nobody's come out with that
wine yet
never understand yeah why don't we
market that filipino grigio how about
yellow wine are you a filipino
uh no vietnamese well look let's tell
people your filipino and make them
sell it okay let's say you smash the
grapes with your feet and sell the wine
what people love her feet dude oh yeah
and then buy one get one free and you
get a bus lamp oh yeah
dude i am down oh yeah i love that i
love everybody
pizza demand is so high so high bro
we're having a little bit of communal
bust in the living room
why why go all to your separate rooms to
jerk off you know what i'm saying it's
2019.
hang up on each other man because you're
now in a living room like a [ __ ]
like a real crew you know like a real
family
this guy's problem should he should he
uh
keep it quiet about tinder that where
they met because that's what his wife
hates
or should he talk about it because they
made it what do you think b that's a
good question man
listen just just say you met at a bar
who gives a [ __ ] who cares
but that's not what he's asking for the
family's older like his families are
they they don't know what tinder is they
don't know what instagram
is so you're gonna have to explain all
that a little white lie is not bad if
she's like
we met at a bar yeah we're married now
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying like get
over it
i don't know that seems aggressive that
seemed like a way it seemed like a very
promise he's driving and [ __ ]
recording this nine-hour
question yeah that's the biggest and
he's going 90 miles an hour
and it was super creepy goes this my
wife
all right dude first of all i love a
creepy dude okay
i work with one second of all i
uh i think but here's the thing if you
want to tell
the the just don't make the reason you
do it to like make fun of your wife or
something or if she feels uncomfortable
saying you met at the mall that's kind
of [ __ ] shitty
did he say them all that's what he said
no no no that's way worse yeah
it's not 1994 anymore i can't say the
mall
same at a nice fancy restaurant at the
bar or some [ __ ] man yeah yeah at least
make it somewhere
nice maybe like the holiday inn had uh
they always have a club at the holiday
inn like a little bar called like
celebrations or you know uh you know
uproar it always has a shitty name you
know you met at waffle house
no oh yeah fun that's a good cop
everybody loves waffle house
no one hates on it there's no perfect
place to meet i don't think is there a
perfect place to meet let's go to the
culture corner yeah
though we know that yeah definitely not
a mall
especially now i feel like malls are
where older guys go pick up high school
girls dude
yeah yeah you're probably right here's
the other thing about tinder this is a
success story i'm not on tinder you
probably are
but all they say is it's a hookup site
dudes are just busting nuts left and
right trying to make these lamps
no one's getting married they they
they're a success story
they got married off tinder that's dope
well is it
what i'm saying he says they're a
success story he says they're a success
that's what i would say
yeah look i think yeah just
[ __ ] i don't know tinder should use them
for marketing everyone trying to [ __ ]
bust nuts and spread disease on tinder
these people are real
they met on there they got a family now
he's driving 90 miles an hour
in his [ __ ] outback subaru on the
road
filming it's a success i think look tell
your boys you met on tinder that's fine
i think if she wants to have some
different errors for her family you
could tell them that
and then you know and that can be that
come up with a cool place though cause
it's hard to keep that lie all the
goddamn time
yeah that's a thing so you met at a
chili's do with chili's yeah everybody
meets the chili's dude they got chips
they got [ __ ] steaks baby back ribs
yeah they have no ovens in the back
everything's made in the microwave and
they bring it out like it was made in an
oven bruh
yeah dude that's america dude so tell
them this where you met who say you met
a marine calendar because we run out of
business and let your wife have some
yeah let your wife sit in the front seat
every now and then dude yeah
yeah she's not rosa parks dick they're
in the front seat all right
yeah but start there and then worry
about the family's judgment she's not
[ __ ]
rosa parks you know what else we got
[Music]